Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now, you can discover Canada and there are many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is, can I have it and go find my own place? And like more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes.
And I did. I got an Airbnb. a little apartment. It faced a park. It was so lovely. I loved the host. And I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah. And I was near a grocery store. I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know. It just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there, you know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff, National Park. Well, listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean,
we love it. Love it. When you're with Amex Platinum, you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit. So the best tap is in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at amex.ca slash yamex. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together, and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi, everyone. We have a fun, fun episode today. It's an All About Character episode. Here's a hint. In real life, this person is my neighbor. And in fact, we carpooled here today. That's right. It is all about Creed Bratton today on Office Lady 6.0. And Creed will be joining us in the studio a little later for our fan Q&A. And I can tell you all, it's a delight. He's just wonderful. Mm-hmm. Start to finish. Yes, the real deal. Well, you know we like to kick things off with the show Bible, and I have been very excited to read the show Bible for Creed. I know. It is wonderful. But we got a fan letter from a fan who wrote her own.
This was so impressive. It came in from Cindy R. in Sydney, Australia, who said, okay, ladies, this isn't a question, but a list of facts, quotes, and moments that my family and I started collecting about six years ago in an effort to better understand creed. They have been doing this for six years. Six years, her family. They have reached the conclusion that he might not be understandable. Cindy went on to say, looking at this list now, I think we may have written the Creed section of the show Bible.
And lady, she did. I compared their list to the show Bible, and their list is actually more detailed. No way. Yes. So I am going to read her family's list. Now, they also included things from deleted scenes, which I'm not going to read because the rules of the show Bible say that only aired material goes in the show Bible. But still, check out her family's list. Here we go.
Creed. Wanted criminal. Definitely stole blood. runs a fake ID business, has been in multiple cults and is also potentially bisexual. Hyde's true identity. Stole the name Creed Bratton
from someone named Creed Bratton. Commits tax fraud implied to have killed someone on Halloween. Doesn't appear to know what his job is, where he works, or any of his coworkers. When swapped, he doesn't seem to notice or care that he's eating a raw potato
instead of an apple. We talked to Crete about that. Attempted to fake his death at one point, has a daughter, his parents are still alive, he grows and eats mung beans in his desk, doesn't appear to know any modern technology. Internet texts nothing. Which might explain something else we talked about with Cree.
Creece. Creed wants three chairs. What are they for? We don't know. He uses the woman's bathroom, has never owned a fridge. Love stealing. Literally says, I love stealing, I love taking things, has definitely done drugs, sells Kelly a tapeworm, and also has a worm guy for worms. Mm-hmm. Has a whole worm guy. No. The character of Creed lives near the quarry,
ate an ice pack, called it a blueberry slurpy pouch, but somehow didn't die. Is very knowledgeable about marijuana strains? Used printer ink to dye his hair. He can't do cartwheels, has four toes, uses a disco ball as a rearview mirror, is very good at Dance Dance Revolution, hates Betty White. Do you remember that one? I had to look this up. No, I don't remember that. I guess in nepotism, he starts following Michael's nephew on Twitter because he isn't talking about Betty White. Doesn't want to hear any more about Betty White. No more. Leave it alone already. In search committee, Creed says, quote, I love my kids. I love ceramic. I love my job. I love wrestling.
He's already made his tombstone. He thinks he's learning scuba at Dunder Mifflin, and he's definitely been flashing people. But, you know, quote, that was just hanging brain. That's so gross. He can catch fish with his bare hands. He prints his own money, and he does not know what a Toblerone is. That's really funny. Quote, how did I get this long triangle? Yes. I loved that. So that is a pretty impressive list, right? It really is.
It really is. Now, there are a few things that were in the show Bible that did not make their family's list. They are that the character of Creed was in an iron lung as a teenager, that he is a chessmaster, has a Swiss passport, has friends in China, and has an alias. William Charles Schneider. Yeah. And he transfers all his debt to William Charles Schneider. There you have it. That was so impressive.
His show Bible, the facts of creed, are so entertaining. There's a lot of crime. There's a lot of shenanigans on Tom Foolery. I don't know why I'm saying all these ye oldy terms. Well, I thought it might be fun to go through our digital clutter, lady. You and I actually have some shared digital clutter that I have. have held on to. It is our text thread with Creed. We have been texting together the three of us for years. Yeah, we have our office peeps text thread, but we've got a side thread that's just you,
me, and Creed. Yep. And I want to share with you guys what it consists of. First of all, he always calls himself Grandpa Creed, and he refers to me as Pumpkin, because remember, he has that line on the show, Pumpkin's out. Yep. And so he calls me Pumpkin. And he always calls Jenna Jen. That's his nickname for her. You'll hear him say that in our interview today. He is the only person in my life who calls me, Jen, and I love it. Okay. Are you ready for an overview of our Creed texts? Yes. I thought this was really fun when you said, lady, I think we need to dig in to our text thread with Creed. I was looking at it. We found very funny things. He sends us a lot of wacky stuff, memes and the gifts and all that stuff.
But he also sends us pictures from his trips with his grandkids. inspirational quotes, like this one that he said is one of his favorites. And we've shared it before on the podcast, but since today is all about Creed, and this is one of his favorite quotes, I want to share it again. I love it. Creed wrote to us and said, I thought I'd send you my favorite cat quote from Alan Watts. When a cat falls out of a tree, it lets go of itself. The cat becomes completely relaxed and lands lightly on the ground. But if a cat were about to fall out of a tree and suddenly make up its mind, that it didn't want to fall, it would become tense and rigid and would be just a bag of broken bones upon landing. In the same way, it is the philosophy of the Tao that we are all falling off a tree
at every moment of our lives. As a matter of fact, the moment we were born, we were kicked off a precipice, and we are falling, and there is nothing that can stop it. So instead of living in a state of chronic tension and clinging to all sorts of things that are actually falling with us, because the whole world is impermanent, be like a cat. You know, I think Creed lives that. I do too. You know? I love that.
I do too. Well, you know, he also will always text us happy birthday, holiday greetings. One year, he texted us, happy New Year to you and your cats. And then he sent a video of a cat figuring out how to open a door. It was genius. My cat, Andi used to do that. We had a conversation about it. But we'll also hear from him for just no reason at all.
Like the time that he randomly sent us a video where a dog and an elephant become friends. And then he texted, oh, come on, ladies, I'm a blubbering mess after this one. He really loves videos where animals like do cutie pie thing. Right. Or when animals help each other out. Yes. Animals working together. This is a thing.
This is a theme. So, yes, the theme is usually animals being really cute. But then every once in a while, we get a curveball. Like, there was a 15-minute dance video he sent us. I remember this. I loved it. You loved it. It was from a French theatrical company titled, oh, Jenna, I'm probably going to get this wrong.
Do you want me to read it? Yes, will you? Okay, here, give it to me. Oh, yes. Well, I'm going to butcher it as well. Here we go. Ria de Grave. of Marguerite Borda
and Pierre Menier. Exactly. But probably I said that wrong. So that's the title. But then when you click on it, there's a description of this dance. Yes. A 15-minute dance.
And the description says, where in a space invaded by mud, eight couples strive to dance the minuet in the rules of the art. And then Creed wrote under it, enjoy this, ladies. Give it some time. It's an investment.
I remember receiving it, and I remember clicking on it and thinking, I must watch this. I remember watching it thinking, I would have never probably found this, if not for Creed. Correct. This is a fascinating piece of art. Yes. Well, we also check in with him, especially when he's on the road touring. One time we reached out and asked him how he was doing, and he wrote this. He said, I'm in Philadelphia for a two-week tour.
It is so cold and snowy, but I love it. miss you girls i mean it's so simple but it's just so sweet i know i also loved our text thread when we were writing our book and we reached out to him for our audiobook and he wrote us the most awesome jingle we thanked him profusely in our text and then he texted us back you're my girls i have no choice grandpa creed takes care of his brood isn't that so sweet yeah i think we should hear it Here's a tall tale you could call it a yarn About the office ladies and the show they spawned They took our story and wrote it all down
Little Angela and her friend POM Jenna and Edge Pumpkin and Pam Go together like eggs and spam Their book's real cute Rudy to toot Jenny and Anne and Jen Which was Pam
I mean it's just so sweet It's the best We got an original song Written about our friendship And our book by Creed Creed He just recorded that at home With his guitar
I mean it's so special to me Well I just loved that trip down memory lane, and you know what? I think we should take a break, and when we come back, we can all share our favorite creed moments. Pura is the smart way to fragrance your home. Customize your scents with app control. Schedule them to fit your life and enjoy premium fragrances that last. And here's something to celebrate. When you start today, your first fragrance set is free. It's the perfect time to discover why everyone's switching to Pura. But hurry, this offer is for a limited
time only. Go now to Pura.com and claim your free set before it's gone. Hi, I'm Nancy Cartwright. You may know me better as the voice of Bart Simpson. On Simpsons Declassified, we're diving into the mysteries that keep the Simpsons forever young. Have you ever wondered how the Simpsons regularly predicts future events? Who better to ask than the show's creators, performers, and writers, the celebrity guests. Be sure to follow and listen to Simpsons Declassified wherever you get your podcasts. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, sometimes we turn to some funny places for support, maybe a hairdresser, a barista, maybe a random stranger in the bathroom for life advice, but not everyone is a therapist. You can find your right
match with BetterHelp. Better Help therapists are clinically trained and credentialed. They work according to a strict code of conduct and are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp does the initial matching work for you, so you can focus on your therapy goals. You'll get a short questionnaire that helps identify your needs and preferences, and then they will match you with a licensed therapist. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Find the one with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies.
That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. All right, we are back, and I think it's time for our Office Ladies team to share their favorite creed moments. We always like to kick this off with a fan letter. This one is from Luke B in Iowa, who said, Creed is my absolute favorite character. And then in parentheses, said, no offense. None taken Luke.
Because of his incredible one-line, insane fly-by comments that many times go overlooked. Season 2, Episode 14, is one of those when he comes in while everyone is trying to figure out what happened in Michael's office. Spoiler alert, it was poop. Creed makes the comment, quote, someone making soup? I believe it's one of the most underrated lines in the entire show. It's such a great random throwaway.
It really is. It really, really is. All right, well, who wants to go first? I'll go first. Okay, Sam. All right, mine was a toss-up between the old man's smell comment and this one. Hey, do you want to tell Stanley that I have asthma?
Because I don't. If it gets out, they won't let me scuba. If I can't scuba, then what's this all been about? What am I working toward? It's so pure. I love it so much. Cassie, what's yours? So my all-time favorite is from murder when Michael,
everyone's doing like the New Orleans characters, and Michael tells Creed that there's been a murder, and Creed's like, oh, yeah, I'll be right back. And then you see him running away. But it's more of a sight gag. So this is my runner-up. Yo, is this his new chair? No, he hasn't picked one yet.
When Pam gets Michael's old chair, I get Pam's old chair. Then I'll have two chairs, only one to go. I'm like, what the heck? I love that one. Angela, what's yours? Okay, mine is from the episode Ultimatum in season seven. So we talk about this a little bit with Creed, but if you remember, Pam has a conference room meeting, and she is putting up a New Year's resolution board
in the office so everyone can try to work towards their new resolution. And she asked different people, what is their resolution? And here's what Creed said. I love it, and then I have a part two. Creed, I noticed you don't have a resolution on the board. What's yours? I want to do a cartwheel, but real casual,
I can not make a big deal out of it, but I know everybody saw it. There's one stunning, gorgeous cartwheel. How's it going? I'm having little trouble motivating. Then, later in that episode, Aaron does a cartwheel in the bullpen. And Creed's reaction is amazing. One, two, three.
I did it. I did a cartwheel. Fuck you. Fuck you. God. Okay. That's it. He just cusses her out.
He's so pissed. All right, Jenna. What about you? All right. Well, I have two. I couldn't. side. My first one is from gay witch hunt. I love this talking head. I'm not offended by homosexuality. In the 60s, I made love to many, many women, often outdoors, in the mud and the
rain. And it's possible a man slipped in. It would be no way of knowing. I just love it. I think he delivers it so well. And then my other favorite is from Fun Run. I've been involved in a number of cults, both as a leader and a follower. He had more fun as a follower. But you make more money as a leader. I mean, it's true. I mean, come on. I mean, come on.
It's so good. Well, I think we should dig into some fan favorite creed moments. BuzzFeed wrote an article titled 27 Creed Bretton moments that will never not be funny. That's how many there are. There's 27, but this doesn't even include deleted scenes and all the other ones that are probably going to be discovered now in the superfan episodes. So in addition to all the ones we just shared, here are some that make all of the fan favorite lists. Okay. I'm going to just share five because there are so many.
Okay. All right. In Coypon, when Michael says, I could get a fish for a five-cent worm, and Crete says, you're paying way too much for worms, man. Who's your worm guy? I love who's your worm guy. Everybody loves that one. Number two, in Niagara Part 2, we learned this about Creed. Dwight says, Parley, my office, five minutes. Pam says parlay. Creed says pirate code. He wants to meet.
Pam goes, So everyone here knows pirate code? And Creed says, I understand it. I can't speak it. Number three, I completely forgot about. And are you ready? What is it? In the episode negotiation,
Creed makes this very fair but disgusting observation. He says, You can only ever ooze two things. sexuality and puss. I do not remember that. That's so gross. Number four, in Dundra Mifflin Infinity, when he actually uses the printer ink to dye his hair
so he could look younger. Remember Michael's like, I would have printed more things, and he's like, but there's no ink, and then it cuts to Creed. Lastly, number five, this makes many, many people's lists. In fact, it's also one of Creed Bratton
in real life's favorite moments. He talked about it with us. Everyone loves it when Creed got to be the manager in search committee. Mm-hmm. There's a compilation clip of this day. It's pretty long, but I'm going to play you the first 50 seconds. We need a new manager. Keep it running.
Do I love being the manager? I love my kids. I love real estate. I love ceramics. I love my job. I love wrestling. Find out what language this is. Most frankly, there, the cloth near my star, e-mer.
or bot. Got it. Okay. Team building. On this side of the room, Stanley, Phyllis, Jim, Ted Elroy. On this side of the room, Pam, Meredith, Phyllis, Creed. He never called a meeting. Bo body.
Bo body. What is the first B stand for? What are we doing? We're making acronyms. Okay. What is the first B stand for? Um... Business.
I like it. Business. Good. Kevin. All right, the O. That's just part of his time as a manager, but it's the best. When he pulls up and he tosses his keys to no one, and then his bow body, and you know what, you can see John laughing. Oh, yeah, yeah. Yeah, he's cracking up.
Well, Creed was John's weakest spot, right? Like, whatever. His Achilles heel, what do you call that? Yes, it was for sure. Yeah, he never regained composure. when Creed was like, you're not real, man. Exactly. Well, I love the character of Creed so much. I love how he came about, Lady, that's just so organically. Like, the writers did not sit down in the room and think him up.
It's like they found him. He was a little treasure just sitting on our set doing background work. Oh, yeah. I would dare to say the writers had no idea the treasure chest that was going to be Creed. Well, now we like to do our areas of interest. Angela, do you want to kick us off? Yes, I am very excited about mine. And so are people that wrote in. Eva S from Tennessee wrote in and said, one of my favorite things about Creed is creed thoughts.gov. Can you read some of the entries? They are so funny. Thanks, love you guys. And Elise Kay from Minnesota said I remember reading hilarious
blog posts from Creed on NBC's website back in the day. Can you try to find these and discuss them? Well, this was my area of interest. I was so excited. This website is still active, you guys. What? Yes. I found it. Creedthoughts.gov. It's there. That's ridiculous. Yes. You just go to creedthoughts.gov. It's there. Really? That's nuts. That's crazy. So the blogs were written by our writers and writers assistants. They were really popular. And when you go to the site, it has a list of blogs. There are entries from May 2007 to August 2008. So there's a lot of blog entries, and they're pretty long. They're full of classic
creedisms, but I grabbed one to share. All right. It is from June 26, 2008. I've always liked uniforms. When I was a kid, I wore sailor suits every day until I was eight. People called me, I'm sorry. Oh, my goodness. Where is this going? I'm sorry. People called me Captain Crapt Stick because of how I dress and the fact that I would carry around a stick with me that I used for poking all sorts of crap. I still have my sailor suit hanging proudly in my closet, but I only break it out when a special lady comes over. It doesn't fit so well anymore, but I still look darn cute in it. In my opinion, every job should have a uniform. Fast food workers, gas station attendance, exterminators, these guys all have it covered already.
I'm pushing for the jobs that make you waste time every morning deciding what to wear. Take my job, for instance. I know I'm not allowed to wear shorts because every time I do, I get yelled at. I also can't wear vests without shirts underneath, so I'm locked into wearing a certain combination of clothing every day. But there are just too many choices. If it were up to me, I'd implement an office worker uniform so you could just wake up every morning, go to your uniform closet, and three seconds later, you're all set. My uniform would consist of three items and three items only. This is fascinating. This has gone in so many directions. I know. I've learned so much. I know, right? Number one, navy blue sweatpants. These are the first item because
they're the most important. When I go home, the first thing I do is put on navy blue sweatpants. You can't find a more comfortable piece of clothing. I thought this is so relatable. The color is great because you can spill all you want and nobody's the wiser. All in all, if the uniform doesn't include navy blue sweatpants, I don't want the job. Number two, a vest. No shirt required. Vests are amazing inventions. They cover up your nipples, which society has decided are unacceptable to see for some reason.
And they're classy. You want to class up a joint? Throw on a vest. You want to add some more class? Make sure that vest is leather. Number three. Wait, I just, so far, we're wearing a leather vest, no shirt, and navy blue sweatpants. Yes.
Okay. Although if you want a different type of material vest, that's fine. But leather is the classiest. Right. Number three. Final item, right? Because he only wants three items. Is it shoes?
Comfy slippers. Oh. Right after I change into my navy blue sweatpants, I slide on my shirt. sheepskin-line slippers. Talk about comfort. These little puppies make it feel like you're walking on a field of soft, paralyzed sheep. I say paralyzed only so you don't picture the sheep as moving. If I could wear slippers to work every day, I'd probably start caring about my job. These three items could change the workplace as we know it. I'm serious, America. Just think about how much more productive we would all be as a country if all office workers wore navy blue sweatpants, vests without shirts,
and comfy slippers. We'd be a comfortably dressed productivity superpower. And honestly, isn't that what all this fighting is about anyway? Lady, I think someone could wear this as a Halloween costume and have like the ultimate deep cut office costume. Oh, that is brilliant, Jenna. Yeah. If someone wore a vest with navy sweatpants, no shirt. And the like sheep lined, right? Is that what he said? Sheepskinned slippers. Yeah. That's your Creed costume right there. It sure is. And if you want to be classy, it's a leather vest. And you're going to be quite comfortable. I don't know, well, what part of the country you live in, you might be a little chilly, but... Please, if anyone dresses in this Creed outfit for Halloween, will you tag us? I hope we can find it, because that's brilliant.
Yeah, I would like to have that. Okay, there it was. That was my Creed area of interest. These blogs are hilarious. I could have read them all day. Great job writers and writers' assistants of the office. I bet they were a lot of fun to write. Well, lady, my area of interest was inspired by a fan letter. It is from Elsa S. Who said, The character of creed seems to draw a lot of inspiration from the real-life creed.
With the lines sometimes blurred between the two, can you share what aspects of creed the character are fictional and which are real? Well, lady, it's true. Over the years, we have shared a lot about how Creed's real life often found its way into the character of Creed, but also how sometimes we don't know what's real and what's fiction. For sure. So I thought it might be fun to do a little Creed Bratton Factor Fiction as my area of interest. Well, lady, I thought we should get to the bottom of this. And why not just go to the source? With Creed? Yes. That's so great. I made a list of questions for the real creed to find out which aspects of his character come from fact, which ones are purely fiction.
Why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we'll get him in here and we'll ask him my questions and also fan questions from our mailbag. Love it. The Twisted Tale of Amanda Knox is an eight-episode Hulu original limited series that blends gripping pacing with emotional complexity. offering a dramatized look as it revisits the wrongful conviction of Amanda Knox for the tragic murder of Meredith Kircher and the relentless media storm that followed. The Twisted Tale of Amanda Knox is now streaming only on Disney Plus. During the Volvo Fall Experience event,
discover exceptional offers and thoughtful design that leaves plenty of room for autumn adventures. And see for yourself how Volvo's legendary safety brings peace of mind to every Christmas. morning commute. This September, Lisa, 2026 X-E-90 plug-in hybrid from $599
biweekly at 3.99% during the Volvo Fall Experience event. Conditions supply, visit your local Volvo retailer or go to
explore Volvo. com. Jen, I was in a hotel a while back. I think it was in New Orleans. And, you know, when the office channel
comes along, you come back in your room and there's nothing but office stuff, you know? Yeah. So this one episode comes on, and you're asking me about the cartwheel. Oh, yes. I love the cartwheel moment.
And there's a look on your face when I'm talking. It's the sweetest, I've got to tell you, it's the sweetest look. It's so endearing. You're going, and just like my kid or something, and just so pleased with dad. And I didn't really notice how sweet it was born. That's a great little moment there, you know. This little tiny stuff. It is.
We all had to pick sort of for the episode today, our favorite creed. moment. And that is mine. That's Angeles. It's so sweet. It's just because it's so sweet. It really is. I mean, I'm just kind of, oh, I just want to do this thing. And I'm, you know, and, oh, gosh. And Pam's really rooting for you. And she's rooting for me too. You know, it's just great. Well, listen, guys, here we are. We've jumped in. Creed is in studio with us. We're already chit-chatting. Yep. You guys carpooled together. You told me it was eventful. Well, here's the thing. We are neighbors. We shared this before. So Creed's like, just text me
And I'll meet you out And so I pull up and he gets in And we start the drive And I went a different way than I normally go And then I couldn't figure out how to get on the freeway You're arguing with Siri I was arguing with Siri And then Creed goes, I got this
He was like, all you need is Creed I was like, all you need is Creed That's true We put that on a T-shirt Put that on a coffee mug for sure But then she gets on the freeway And there's someone going to say she Come on, what are you doing?
And she's just, she drives around to the right and drives around to flip some, no, she did not, she did not. She did not. Here's the thing. It was the ramp when you get on, and it says one car per green. And there's two cars. You were irate. I was. You were a little bit.
The light turns green. Neither of them go. How dare they? And then I guess I got a little sassy. You did. And Creed goes, creed said, I think that's Texas attitude in California driving. There's another mind. And I said, but this gets stuff done.
Because she just shut around him and just, boom, you were gone. Ben Creed started laughing so hard, and we just got so tickled. It was so good. It made me laugh. He was like, we have to tell everyone how sassy you are on the freeway. I'm just saying, just abide by the law. Do the things we all are supposed to do. Turn signals.
Turn signals. And then I'm not going to call you a dumb, dumb. Yeah. Yeah. I agree. Yeah. She's not arguing with this. No, not at all.
Creed, I want to kick things off. I have some questions for you. And these are things about your character, Creed Bratton, that we would like to know if they are also true about you, the real Creed Bratton. Because you know your character blurred the lines of fact and fiction sometimes. It's confusing being me. It is? I speak to myself in the third person a lot because sometimes I don't even know where I'm coming from.
And I question, I question my own motives. This should be an interesting session then. Yes, it should be. We'll see what happened. I'm actually to see what he's going to say. Okay, well, here's the first question. Were you in a band called the grassroots? Yes, I was.
We know this is true. This is true. I think they know this, the fans, yes. So that is fact. Fact. It's just what we're saying, fact, fact. So how long were you in the band? Fact.
No, I was in the band. I did four albums, so it was four years. A very, wow. Yeah. Four albums in four years. That's very prolific. We put an album out of a year. Wow.
Y'all were busy. We were busy. Okay. Here's the next question. Did you ever have a radio show called Wacky Weed Creed? Not fact. Okay. Total fiction.
That's Oscar. Oscar thought that, but he was wrong. Okay. Were you in an iron lung as a teenager? Briefly. Wait, what? No. Come on.
No, okay, I wasn't. But do you see how you had us? This was what it was like being on set with you because we'd be like, really? And then you'd start laughing. When I was a kid, I would do this all the time for just a defense mechanism to tell stories all my life. And sometimes I would get people and they would believe. I have this innate ability to make people believe what I say, as you know. Yes.
And some people would find out that I was kidding. And they would get angry sometimes, you know. I finally had the period of time where I had to stop just josh and around. Josh and around, because people who took it took it too. I was, you know, just being an a... Yeah. All right. Next one.
Have you ever grown or eaten mung beans in real life? I have. I've done both. Really? Yes, I've eaten them. I've praised them. I've had little shrines for mung beans in my home. It's kind of like a worship thing, actually.
Yeah. Is this... Is there any part of this that's true? No, but mung beans are, you know, I like... I think I like alfalfa and ratty sprouts more than mung beans. But I do, there's a slight, small subcoccal of my heart that likes mung beans. You're a very healthy eater. I am, and I watch what I eat, you know.
Yeah. Did you really eat mung beans on the office? Did they give you actual mung beans? Did you ever eat them? Right. But I did eat them. And what did they taste like? And I ate that potato, by the way, too.
You did the raw potato? I talked about that. Yeah. When they switch out the apple for the potato. I absolutely ate the raw potato. And I couldn't tell that much difference, you know, that I don't have a really great sense of spell. Wait, that's so funny.
I chomped right down on that animal. And now, wait, what does a mung bean taste like? I've never had one. Memorable, some. Memorable. There used to be a song back in the 50s. Memorable mung beans, I recall. Now it's memorable mung beans.
I can't remember the exact melody of it now. But it's kind of like spring that's gone a little rancid. That's, it sounds like a bean that has turned, mung bean. It sounds like maybe something that's fermenting. That's exactly what it is, Jen. It's a fermented bean. Okay. But it's a fresh, and the irony, too, it's a brand new fresh, brand new germinating out, starting
its life, but it's already rancid at the start of its life. kind of like some people's careers but anyway here we go all right next question do you have a daughter I have a daughter ami
do you have how many kids do you have I have two children you have a son and a daughter okay Bo and Ami and now you're a grandpa and now I'm a grandpa
so great have you ever been in a cult that you know of what are the statute of limitations that stuff like this. Oh, no. I, I, I, I, I, I, there was a time.
It was a time that people put me up to it in a, like a white robe. I recall and, uh, burn some incense. Well, right now, as you know, there is a cult of creed because of the show. There's no joke. So I guess you are the leader of a cult now. Well, right now, I, maybe I was when I was younger, but right now I am a leader of a cult because there's the cult of creed. And my lawyer recently, there's, there's,
there's people all over the world now. Anytime you can see the office, they've started the little cult. There's a little thing there. Would they burn incense, you know, treat, treat the chant my name. I was in Norway, this is no joke.
My lawyer said there was a heavy metal group there that's part of the cult of creed. They've sacrificed a small animal in your name. What? And I had to call them and said, look, I appreciate the gesture, but cease and desist. Can't do this.
Can't do it. Horrible. I don't hurt anything in my name. Don't hurt anything like, because I know. It's horrible. Because that's not you. No. I would not want that.
No, I would not want that, you know. No. I mean, the thought of it that they did that for me was moving, but not not what they did. Yeah. Their passion for your character. The passion for my character, yes. Is any of that true? No.
No. Oh, my God. Read again, dang it. What are you doing? At a boom. At a boom. At the very end, you had that twinkle in your eyes. And I was like, son of a bitch.
I remember the thing I said about. We still believed it. We believe it every time. You were just in Norway. So I thought, oh, I don't know. I was. Maybe. Oh, that's such a beautiful country, too.
Yeah, I've heard. It's really pretty. Yeah. Lovely, lovely. Clean. So clean. With no creepy cults. And there's no creepy cults.
是啊，我听说了。真的很漂亮。对呀。太棒了，太棒了。很干净。非常干净。而且没有可怕的邪教。而且也没有可怕的邪教。
No one has sacrificed any animals, folks in my name. Not that I know of. All right. Next question. Are you good at chess? I'm, I can play. I'm not going to beat I'm not going to beat rain
大家放心，没有人以我的名义献祭过任何动物。至少我不知道。好了。下一个问题。你擅长下棋吗？我，我会下。我可赢不了 我可赢不了雷恩
or my son but I can play a small child who's just learned they've just shown him the basic basic moves you know
或我儿子，但我可以和那些刚学会下棋的小朋友过招，就是那种刚有人教给他们最基础最基础的走法的小朋友，你知道的
he's still working to where the word move the night stuff like that could probably beat him okay can use scuba I used to
他还处在琢磨“走子”和“马”怎么走这种阶段，我大概能赢他。好吧，你会潜水吗？我以前会
until I broke my ear drum oh how did you break your eardrum this is true now this is true I was horseing around in a pool with a bunch of friends in college for the water polo team and for somebody throwing through a football. So we were starting to play football in a pool. Yeah. Not a good
直到我把耳膜打破了。哦，你是怎么把耳膜打破的？这是真的，千真万确。上大学时我和一群水球队友在游泳池里胡闹，有人扔了一个美式橄榄球。于是我们开始在泳池里玩橄榄球。对。这不是个好
idea. And we didn't have our little, those days you don't have the protected things for years they have for water polo players. Now, yeah. So I just caught an elbow, broke the, broke the ear drum. And then, uh, then I was still able to scuba dive. And I got it. I had a scuba. I had the whole thing. Did scuba dive. Yes. Then I was in Hawaii with my six. And then I was in Hawaii with my son, and I was in the way we were going down, and we were just snorkeling. And the woman next to me dropped her mask in her snorkel, being a gentleman. I went down after to get it for her. I went down too far. Pow. It broke the tympatic membrane again. And now it's just messed up. What is that like for you when you fly in an airplane with the air pressure?
主意。而且我们当时没有戴那种小护具，早年间水球运动员戴的那种保护耳朵的东西，现在有了。所以我不小心挨了一肘子，耳膜就破了、破了。然后呢，呃，然后我竟然还能去水肺潜水。我还去弄了。我有一套潜水装备。我全套都有。还真去水肺潜水了。没错。后来我和我儿子一起去了夏威夷。然后我带着儿子在夏威夷，我们在往下潜，当时只是在浮潜。我旁边的那位女士把面镜和呼吸管掉水里了，作为一个绅士。我潜下去帮她捡。我潜得太深了。砰。我的鼓膜又破了。从那以后，这耳朵就彻底废了。你坐飞机时气压变化对你有什么影响？
It's not bad. It's not bad. I get anything else. She still have to clear a little more, but not bad. But I came up and I could see, and I couldn't find my way back to the surface and I was panicking a little bit because my body wouldn't go in the direction that I was trying to swim. Yeah. I got up there and Beau was laughing.
还行，不赖。其他倒没什么。我还是得稍微做一下耳压平衡，不过还行。当时我浮上来，我能看见东西，却找不到回水面的路了，我当时有点恐慌，因为我的身体不听使唤，无法朝我试图游去的方向游。对。我游出水面后，博（Beau）在那儿笑。
He said, did you get it? He looks at me. He said, Dad, you're white. And I went, oh, he jumped in. And I was panicking. Yeah, that's scary. Yeah. You lost your sense of balance and, and, yeah, direction.
他说：“你拿到了吗？”他看着我。他说：“爸爸，你的脸都白了。”然后我说：“哦。”他跳了下来，而我当时正在恐慌。对，那挺吓人的。是啊。你失去了平衡感，还有，对，方向感。
I lost all my equilibrium. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. But I'm okay now, folks. Yeah. All right. Do you have four toes on one of your feet? I was, yes, I do. On my right foot, I was, uh...
我失去了所有的平衡觉。对。哇。是的。不过我现在没事了，各位。对。好了。你的一只脚上有四个脚趾吗？我，是的，我有的。在我的右脚上，我，呃……
No. No, no, I know this one. You have ten toes. Yeah. How do you know? You've seen my feet. I don't know. I've seen your feet. I've seen your feet. When? Okay, you were barefoot, I think in the finale, when we find out you're homeless and you've been living in the office. Yeah, you're right. You're right. I'm pretty sure. You're brushing your teeth and You're in your towel or something, and you walk out. Okay, but a better story is that I was in in Scandinavia again at a clog dancing.
不对。不对，不对，这个我知道。你有十个脚趾。对。你怎么知道？你见过我的脚。我不知道。我见过你的脚。我见过你的脚。什么时候？好吧，你光着脚，我想是在大结局里，当时我们发现你无家可归，一直住在办公室里。对，你说的对。你说的对。我挺确定的。你在刷牙，而且你围着浴巾什么的，然后你走出来。好吧，不过一个更好的故事是，我当时在斯堪的纳维亚半岛，又是去跳木屐舞。
Stop it. And some drunk Viking stomped on my toe and broke it. And then there's a hole with hairy feet that covers the hole. That's what I said to Steve in the scene. It's an ad lib. Do you remember that? No. There's a little ad lib under my voice going like to, well, the hair, I said the hair covers it up mostly.
住手。然后一个喝醉的维京人踩在我的脚趾上，把它踩断了。然后“有一个长满毛的脚趾洞盖住了那个洞。”这就是我在那个场景里对史蒂夫（Steve）说的话。那是即兴发挥。你还记得吗？没有。我声音底下有一个小小的即兴台词，说的是“嗯，毛发”，我当时说毛发差不多把它盖住了。
Oh, no, yes. The hair covers it up. The hair covers it up. But not the part about the clogging in. No, no, no. No, no, I should have. That was came later. Okay.
哦，不，是的。毛发把它盖住了。毛发把它盖住了。但不是关于木屐舞的那部分。不，不，不。不，不，我当时应该说的。那是后来才有的。好吧。
All right. My final factor fiction question, can you catch a fish with your bare hands? Well, that would be really, they're so slippery. Yeah. Now, I really doubt it unless you're Bruce. Bruce Lee probably could. Yeah. If he goes around.
好的。我的最后一个事实还是虚构的问题：你能赤手空拳抓到鱼吗？嗯，那可真够呛，它们太滑了。对。现在的话，我真的很怀疑，除非你是李小龙。李小龙大概可以。对。如果他四处出击的话。
Someone like that. Yeah, someone's super quick. Somebody, he'd have to go, he'd have to go like this, whack, and get a finger up in the mouth. Yeah. Hop, like that. I'm impressed that you came up with how to do it so quickly. I think... That's exactly what you'd have to do.
像那样的人。对，动作超级快的人。那种人，他必须得出手，他得像这样，啪地一下，把手指塞进鱼嘴里。对。就像那样，一下子。我很佩服你能这么快想出怎么操作。我觉得……这绝对是你必须要做的动作。
That's so smart. If you tried to grab by the tail, listen to have a big spiky tail, you could grab it like this and go, the tail would stop like that. You know why I think you know this? Right. I'll never forget. During the pandemic, we would trade texts about what are you watching,
太聪明了。如果你试图抓尾巴，听着，鱼有一条带刺的大尾巴，你如果像这样去抓它，鱼尾巴就会这样拍打。你知道为什么我觉得你知道这个吗？没错。我永远不会忘记。大流行期间，我们会互相发短信，问对方在看什么，
what are you binge watching? And Creed was like, alone. You got to see it, Anne. You've got to watch alone. I love that stuff. So then Josh and I get into it. it. And we start watching it. And I'm texting Creed. And I was like, Josh wants you to know he'll never look at a small animal the same way again because they're all so hungry. It's like a squirrel.
你在疯狂追看什么剧？克里德（Creed）就说：独行侠（Alone）。你一定要看，安（Anne）。你一定要看《独行侠》。我太喜欢那类节目了。于是乔什（Josh）和我迷上了它。我们开始看这个节目。我给克里德发短信。我说：乔什想让你知道，他再也不会用以前的眼光看待小动物了，因为它们都饿疯了。就像松鼠一样。
Anything they can get. Oh, yeah. It's a, it's a meat. It's a barbecue thing, you know. So they're out there just catching fish by hand and trying to trap little animals. They're making their own nets and stuff. And they're trying to trap animals because they're so hungry. Twice in my life. When Beau was little, we were fishing. Bass fishing. This is before I got in a trout fishing. And I look at him like, just, hey, bow. And I reach it, and I go, walking out a turtle. The water is like this.
任何它们能弄到的东西。哦，对。那是个，那是肉，是个烧烤派对，你懂的。所以它们就在野外用手抓鱼，试图捕捉小动物。它们自己制作网之类的东西。它们千方百计想捕捉动物，因为它们太饿了。我这辈子有过两次。博还小的时候，我们在钓鱼。钓大口黑鲈。那是在我迷上钓鳟鱼之前。我看着他，就像是，嘿，博。然后我伸手，我一抓，抓出来一只乌龟。水大概这么深。
Second time, I'm with a guy. This is before, way for the office, and after the grassroots, I'm working, we're just doing labor work. Sice, cutting down fields for fire, fire breaks. Sure. Like that. And I look down these two holes like this, and I go, hey, Ray, he's down the road like this. And I go, I have gloves on like this. And I look, and I drop the side, like this quietly,
第二次，我和一个家伙在一起。那是在这之前，远在《办公室》之前，在草根（Grassroots）之后，我在工作，我们只是做体力活。割草，为了防火清理林地防火带。没错。就像那样。我看到这两个洞就像这样，然后我说，嘿，雷，他在路的另一头就像这样。然后我说，我戴着这样的手套。我看着，然后把手悄悄伸下去，像这样，
and go up through the holes. And I go, and this is honest and God truth. I go, and I grab two squirrels, swirl in each hand like this and hold them up like to all the other guys working there and went, going, how in the hell did you do that? It was a hero moment. So you probably could grab a fish back in the day, I would say. I had some of a turtle and two squirrels with your bare hands. I did, girls.
顺着洞口伸进去。然后我说，这绝对是千真万确的实话。我说，我抓了两只松鼠，两只手各抓一只松鼠，像这样把它们举起来，举给所有其他在那儿干活的人看，然后说道：“你到底是怎么做到这一点的？”那是个英雄时刻。所以我想你当年大概真的能抓到鱼，我还得说。你赤手空拳抓过一只乌龟和两只松鼠。我真的抓过，女孩们。
Okay. I did. I'm kind of proud of that, actually. You can see, kind of chuffed. as the English would say. I didn't know that squirrels lived in holes in the ground. They do. There are squirrels that they burrow.
好吧。我确实抓过。其实我对此还挺骄傲的。你可以看出来，我有点沾沾自喜。正如英国人所说的那样。我不知道松鼠是住在地洞里的。它们确实住。有些松鼠会打洞。
Ground squirrels. And they're smaller. And we actually are having a thing in our backyard. They're like, they're burrowing in all these little places in our yard. Social media is not much on the ground scores. They're more the popular ones with the Vidal Sassoon coats and stuff. They get all the press. They get all the good press.
地松鼠。而且它们体型更小。其实我们后院现在就遇到了这种情况。它们就像是在，它们在我们院子里所有这些小地方打洞。社交媒体不太关注地松鼠。它们更喜欢那些顶着维德·沙宣（Vidal Sassoon）发型之类的高颜值松鼠。它们包揽了所有的媒体曝光。它们得到了所有的好名声。
You guys, I have a weird question. Sure. And this is something that I muse about with my family. My kids are annoyed by this question. but I am haunted by it. Oh. And it has to do with squirrels and birds. Where are all of the dead squirrels and the dead birds?
各位，我有一个奇怪的问题。请说。这是我经常和家人琢磨的一件事。我孩子们对这个问题感到很烦。但我却对此魂牵梦萦。哦。这和松鼠还有鸟类有关。那些死去的松鼠和死去的鸟类都去哪儿了？
Where are they? Why don't we see them? The crows. Where do they go? The ravens. Oh, other animals come to eat them. Other animals come and pick them up. Like, why don't, where are they?
它们在哪儿？为什么我们看不到它们？乌鸦。它们去哪儿了？渡鸦。哦，其他动物来吃它们。其他动物会来把它们叼走。就像，为什么不，它们都在哪儿？
Are they dead in the tree? Are they dead in the ground? They're in their bellies. Like, where are they? Well, the ravens, if you see stuff on the side of the road, you see the ravens down there, take cleaning them up. I guess that's true. I mean, I, this is really gross, but there's a hawk that kind of lives in my neighbor's tree. And I walked out one day, like, to go to my little garage office.
它们是死在树上吗？还是死在地上？它们在它们的肚子里。就像，它们都在哪儿？嗯，渡鸦，如果你看到路边有动物尸体，你会看到渡鸦在那里，把它们清理干净。我想也是。我是说，这真的有点恶心，但我邻居的树上住着一只鹰。有一天我走出门，比如要去我那个小车库办公室。
And there were like innards just in the like the pavers, like little tiny intestine, little tiny. And I was like, oh my gosh. And Josh was like, I bet the hawk got a squirrel or something. But I'm saying like birds and squirrels who have died by natural causes. Or suicide. Oh, God. Right. You don't know.
铺路砖上散落着内脏，就像小小的肠子，非常小的一段。当时我就想：哦，天哪。乔什就说：我敢打赌，那只鹰抓了一只松鼠什么的。但我的意思是，那些死于自然原因的鸟类和松鼠呢？还是自杀。哦，天哪。没错。你根本不知道。
We don't know. We don't know. So not something that was prey, but like something, like a very old bird or something or a disease, like a squirrel that died of a disease. And no one wants to eat it and it's just dead somewhere. Yeah. I don't know. I mean, I think Creed, you kind of answered the question, which is that when an animal dies, another animal will eat that dead animal, I guess.
我们不知道。我们不知道。所以不是被捕食的猎物，而是某种，比如一只极老的鸟什么的，或者是因为生病死去的动物，比如一只死于疾病的松鼠。没有人想吃它，它就死在某个地方。对。我不知道。我的意思是，克里德，你算是回答了这个问题，那就是当一只动物死去时，另一只动物会吃掉那只死去的动物，我猜。
If the animal's there, let's say it's old, it's writing its memoirs, that little nagging cough, then boom, it's done. It's over like that. The hawks and the ravens watching him, you know, checking their watch it to see what they're going to die. I don't she like souping today. I'm just going to wait it out. Raven's got his little Fitbit on. You're like, well, I just wondered if in all of your nature show watching, if they explain where squirrels and birds go to die.
如果那只动物还在那儿，假设它老了，正在写回忆录，咳嗽声不断，然后，轰的一声，它就完蛋了。就像这样瞬间结束。鹰和渡鸦在一旁看着它，你知道的，看着表计算它什么时候死。我不知道她今天会不会喝汤？我还是等它断气吧。渡鸦戴着他的小Fitbit手环。你会想，我只是想知道，在你看过的所有自然节目中，它们有没有解释过松鼠和鸟类死后会去哪里。
I can tell you this interesting story. I'm at my backyard on Ethel, when I lived on Ethel and Longridge, doing the only one the show was on. And I was out of the pool one day, and I was sitting out there having my green tea and after work, and I look up at the U's at the house. And there's a little bird nest in there with little baby birds. And all of a sudden, I say the squirrel comes down a pipe, comes over, grabs a baby bird. Because squirrels will eat baby birds.
我可以告诉你这个有趣的故事。我在埃特尔街（Ethel）的后院，当我住在埃特尔街和朗里奇街（Longridge）交界处时，当时剧集还在热播。有一天我从泳池上来，坐在那里喝着我的绿茶，那是下班后，我抬头看着屋顶的屋檐。那里有一个小鸟巢，里面有小鸟宝宝。突然间，我看到一只松鼠顺着水管爬下来，走过去，抓起了一只小鸟宝宝。因为松鼠会吃小鸟。
Squirrels are terrible. Squirrels. You don't know this. Squirrels ate a hummingbird right outside my window. They're the evil creatures of the world. They are mean and they're terrible. There should be, they boycott a lot of things, but squirrels should be right on the list, you know. I know.
松鼠太可怕了。松鼠。你们不知道这一点。松鼠就在我窗外吃掉了一只蜂鸟。它们是世界上邪恶的生物。它们既卑鄙又可怕。它们本该被，人们抵制很多东西，但松鼠绝对应该名列其中，你知道的。我懂。
I'm wrong with you, Jen. You're vicious. Well, on that note, squirrels are evil. I would like to kick off our fan Q&A. All right, let's do it, lady. Fans wrote in, Creed, they love you so much. Oh. Let's start with Oliver T. from Wolverhampton, England, who says, I love Creed.
你怎么回事，詹（Jen）。你太恶毒了。好了，话虽如此，松鼠确实很邪恶。我想开启我们的粉丝问答环节。好的，开始吧，女士。粉丝们写信来了，克里德，他们太爱你啦。哦。让我们从英国伍尔弗汉普顿（Wolverhampton）的奥利弗·T（Oliver T.）开始，他说：我爱克里德。
He is my favorite character in the show and didn't get nearly enough screen time. My question is, what was his favorite Creed moment or storyline? Man, just there's so, you know, you know, there's just so many. And by the way, Wilberton, Walton, where's, Wilverhampton. Wolverhampton, yes, sir. I used to think, well, you know, I can't capable of doing more stuff. I should get more. In retrospect, the lines they gave me just the right amount was perfect.
他是我在剧中角色里最喜欢的，而且他的出场时间远远不够。我的问题是，他最喜欢的克里德时刻或故事情节是什么？天哪，简直有太多了，你知道的，你知道的，简直有太多了。顺便说一句，伍尔弗汉普顿，沃尔顿，哪儿，伍尔弗汉普顿，是的，长官。我以前总觉得，嗯，你知道的，我有能力做更多的事。我应该得到更多。但回过头来看，他们给我的台词量恰到好处，堪称完美。
It was perfect. Too much, a little more. It would have lost the appeal, I think, you know. I think it was just, and I thought about this a lot. it turned out just right. Absolutely perfect. Boy, well, I have to say, obviously, I enjoyed it. It was scary, a scary, you know, baptism by fire
完美无缺。太多了，或者再多一点。那样就会失去吸引力，我想，你知道的。我觉得这就刚刚好，而且我对此深思熟虑过。最终呈现出来的一切都恰到好处。简直完美。天哪，好吧，我必须得说，很显然，我很喜欢。那是令人胆战心惊的，一次惊心动魄的，你知道的，烈火般的洗礼
but the scene with the Halloween episode with Steve working with that at his rate of speed that he works at, you know, and not knowing what was going to happen. That was very satisfying. But all the little bits, you know, which ones, Pam, you know, Did Michael get his new chair yet, you know? The thing with you with the Nicholson's, you know, what do you do? Yeah, well, they have this bag of Nicholson. You're a useless.
但万圣节那一集的场景，和史蒂夫一起工作，配合他那种工作节奏，你知道的，而且根本不知道接下来会发生什么。那真的让人非常满足。但所有那些小片段，你知道的，到底是哪些，帕姆，你知道的，迈克尔拿到他的新椅子了吗，你知道的？你和尼科尔森一家的事，你知道的，你是做什么的？哦，是的，他们有一袋尼科尔森。你真是个废物。
Yeah, and you're like, don't worry about Andrea. She's the office bitch, yes, stuff like that. And everything that thinks it would be the manager when I was driving the Porsche and playing the finale. But it's all those little bits just to keep going, the fodder that kept going. I got such joy out of it. And I laughed, looks like you did. Every time we'd have a table read, I get to see, oh, boy, I can't, I just can't wait to do this line, you know? Yeah.
对，然后你说：别担心安吉拉（Angela）。她就是办公室里的碧池，对，诸如此类。还有所有那些以为我会成为经理的桥段，当时我开着保时捷，还有大结局的表演。但所有那些不断延续的小片段，那些源源不断的素材。我从中获得了巨大的快乐。我笑得前仰后合，你们看起来也是。每次我们进行剧本围读时，我都会看到：哦，天哪，我迫不及待地想念这段台词了，你知道吗？对。
Well, we did get a fan question from Layton R. in Folsom, California, who said, Your time as acting manager in season seven is a fan favorite moment. And Layton wants to hear, did you enjoy that spotlight, or did you prefer being the mysterious side character? Oh, I just said it, didn't I? You did. You said you liked it. I did like it. I certainly enjoyed driving the Porsche. Yeah. Really? Have you ever driven a car like that before? Yeah, I had one. I had a Porsche back in my grassroots days. Yeah. You've always loved a zippy car. I do like it. But I still have a zippy car. I've ridden with you and your zippy car. I'm not going to talk about how you drive.
好吧，我们确实收到了来自加州福尔松（Folsom）的莱顿·R（Layton R.）的粉丝提问，她说：你在第七季中扮演代理经理的时间是粉丝最喜欢的时刻之一。莱顿想听听，你很享受那种成为焦点的感觉，还是更喜欢做那个神秘的配角？哦，我刚才已经说过了，不是吗？确实说过。你说过你挺喜欢的。我确实挺喜欢的。我当然很享受开保时捷。真的吗？你以前开过那样的车吗？对，我有一辆。我在草根乐队时期就有一辆保时捷。对。你一直都很喜欢拉风的车。我确实喜欢。不过我现在还有一辆拉风的车。我和你一起坐过你那辆拉风的车。我可不打算讨论你的开车方式。
No, no, you're right. You're right. But Matt, a lot of people don't know this, you normally have sandbags and a barricade. And he'd be behind a barricade just in case there'd be a stop for the tires. And in any shoot normally, Matt was just standing there with the camera. And I come up there right in front of him like that. He trusted me. And I said, are you sure? I trust you. Are you sure?
不，不，你说的对。你说的对。不过马特（Matt），很多人都不知道这一点，你通常得放沙袋和路障。他就得躲在路障后面，以防轮胎刹不住。而在任何常规拍摄中，马特就站在那儿扛着摄像机。我开着车径直朝他冲过去，就像那样。他信任我。我说：你确定吗？我信任你。你确定吗？
I trust you. And we did it. Dang. That's amazing. I didn't know that. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Most people would never do that normally.
我信任你。我们就这么拍了。天哪。太惊人了。我当时并不知道。哦，是的。是的。正常情况下，绝大多数人是绝对不会那样做的。
You know, Creed, there are a lot of your moments that ended up getting deleted for time, which is true of all of us. But there are Reddit threads upon Reddit threads dedicated to Creed deleted scenes. You are like the favorite character for deleted scenes and deleted moments. Really? Oh, my gosh. Yes. So many fun ones.
你知道吗，克里德，你有很多精彩片段最后因为片长原因被删减了，我们所有人其实都有这种情况。但Reddit上到处都是专门讨论克里德被删减片段的帖子。你简直是删减镜头和被删减桥段里的最爱角色。真的吗？哦，天哪。是的。有太多有趣的片段了。
Wow. Yeah. And I think a lot of those are being added back to the Peacock Superfan episodes. And that's going to be so fun. Yeah. That's amazing, you know. Yeah. Greg, we couldn't use the
哇。对。而且我觉得其中很多片段都被重新加回了Peacock的超级粉丝剪辑版（Superfan episodes）里。那可太有意思了。对。这太棒了，你知道的。对。格雷格（Greg），我们当时不能用那个
Bruce Cruz when I played the guitar. Yes, yes, that was one of them. It was just too long. Yeah, yeah. He said, he's so good. He said, he's so good, but it was just too long. I said, I hope you understand, but we love it, but it's just too long, you know. Yeah.
布鲁斯·克鲁兹（Bruce Cruz）当我弹吉他的那段。对，对，那是其中之一。时间实在太长了。对，对。他说：他太棒了，他弹得太棒了，但就是太长了。我说：我希望你能理解，我们很喜欢它，但它真的太长了，你知道的。对。
A little tidbit there. I recorded it the night before at the studio with Dylan O'Brien and Bob Field, but it's grandtones. Sure. And then I just came in the studio, and he had his, left-handed strap. So I just, by the way he plays, it's different than a lot of left-handers. So I just turned it over like this and played for it.
这里有个小花絮。那是前一天晚上我在录音室和迪伦·奥布莱恩（Dylan O'Brien）以及鲍勃·菲尔德（Bob Field）一起录的，不过那是盛大音调（Grandtones）。当然。然后我走进录音室，他拿着他的左手吉他背带。所以根据他的弹奏方式，这和很多左撇子不同。所以我只是把它像这样翻过来弹奏。
So when you see me playing that left-hand guitar, a lot of people say, well, he's a right-hander. He wouldn't be playing that guitar. So that's the explanation. That's a little nugget there. And also, we were going to play it live, but we realized out there, the reber was going to be bouncing on the amps and stuff. It was to logistically impossible. We had to mime it.
所以当你看到我弹那把左手吉他时，很多人会说，嗯，他是右撇子啊。他怎么会弹那把吉他呢？所以这就是解释。这算是一个小干货。而且，我们原本打算现场弹奏的，但我们在现场意识到，混响会在音箱之类的设备上产生回音。从后勤角度来说这根本不可能实现。我们只能对口型。
We had to mime it, you know. And I really wanted to play live. Yeah. Yeah, but it's okay. But you got to eventually play live on the set, which is so beautiful. Yes, yes, yes. And that's one of the most touching moments when the fans are there at my show and I close with all the faces, you know.
我们只能对口型，你知道的。我当时真的很想现场弹奏。对。对，不过没关系。但你最终还是在片场现场弹奏了，那真的太美妙了。是的，是的，是的。那是全剧最感人的时刻之一，当粉丝们出现在我的演唱会现场，我以一张张熟悉的面孔作为尾声，你知道的。
And I get, I get, I'm looking out of the, you know, it's amazing. Emotional connection from, it's not the song. The song is good, but without the office, we're saying goodbye to all of us. We're seeing goodbye to us. And that song, gets that emotion out of people. It's powerful. It's a beautiful moment. All right.
我当时，我看着，你知道的，这太惊人了。那种情感上的连接，不仅仅是因为这首歌。这首歌很好，但没有了《办公室》，我们是在向所有人告别。我们是在向彼此告别。而那首歌，能把人们心中的这种情感勾勒出来。这很有感染力。这是一个美丽的时刻。好了。
Fan question from one of our very own office ladies members, Ainsley. She wants to know, what did you do on your computer while other cast members were filming scenes? Spider Solitaire. Oh, yeah? Yeah, Spider Solitaire. Because I didn't have a working computer. I think only Oscar had one for a long time in the beginning. But I think eventually everybody got one.
来自我们办公室女士播客的忠实粉丝之一——艾恩斯利（Ainsley）的粉丝提问。她想知道，当其他演员在拍戏时，你在电脑上都在干什么？蜘蛛纸牌。哦，是吗？对，蜘蛛纸牌。因为我没有一台能联网的电脑。我想早期很长一段时间里只有奥斯卡（Oscar）有一台。不过我想最终每个人都有一台了。
Everybody got one eventually. I didn't. Ever? No, I don't think so. Maybe I did. So you never had Internet? You just had the Solitaire game? I'm demented someone because I've had, you know, facialty and stuff, you know.
最后每个人都有一台。我没有。从来没有？没有，我不这么觉得。也许我有过吧。所以你从来没有过互联网？你只有纸牌游戏？我觉得有人把我当成老古董了，因为我当时，你知道的，老态龙钟什么的，你知道的。
I can't believe that. I might have. Is it possible that you got Internet and didn't know? And no one told you? That's probably the case. And you're so. Sometimes I was like, oh my gosh, great. The way you were positioned in the bullpen, no one has.
我真不敢相信。我可能真的有。有没有可能是你有了互联网却根本不知道？而且没人告诉你？那很有可能。而且你太。有时候我就想，哦，天哪，太棒了。你在办公区座位的那个位置，根本没人能……
You could see your computer. Who knows what he did, and you only played Solidair. Oh, that's very fun. I sure wrote a lot of music on that show. You did. In the green room. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah?
你可以看到你的电脑。谁知道他做了什么，而你只玩了纸牌。哦，那太好玩了。我敢说我在那个节目里写了好多歌。你确实写了。在化妆间里。哦，是吗。哦，是吗？
I was always grabbing that guitar and going to the green room waiting for, you know, everybody to show up. And I wrote a bunch of us. I wrote two albums in that green room, basically, and in my trailer. I didn't know that. All right, let's see. We have a fan question from Sabrina S. and her fiancé, Joey, from Chicago, Illinois.
我总是抓起那把吉他，去化妆间等着，你知道的，等大家都来。然后我写了一堆……基本上我在那个化妆间和我的房车里写了两张专辑。我不知道这件事。好吧，我们来看看。我们有一个来自伊利诺伊州芝加哥的粉丝 Sabrina S. 和她的未婚夫 Joey 的提问。
And they said, our question for Creed, who has clearly had and continues to have such an iconic life, what do you consider to be one of your biggest accomplishments? Gosh, well, it has to be the road I was going down in my life. Wow, I'm going to get modeling or anything with my family. and all my debaucheries and stuff, you know, back in my rock and roll days, that now I have such a tight, loving family with such support in the family. It turns out to be all this other stuff is wonderful,
他们说，我们给克里德的问题是，他显然曾过着、并且现在也继续过着如此具有标志性的人生，你认为你最大的成就之一是什么？天哪，好吧，那一定是我人生中曾走过的那条路。哇，我本来可能会去搞模特或者因为我的家人之类的事……还有我那些放荡不羁的事情，你知道的，回到我玩摇滚的那些日子，而现在我拥有这样一个紧密、充满爱意的家庭，并且得到了家庭如此多的支持。事实证明，所有这些别的东西都很棒，
but that family connection is so strong. That gives me most joy and my friendships and my friends, you know. And I'm now putting my hands out at my two girls who are like my daughters from the show, basically, you know. And you always were kind of in a way, you know. I always felt that. Well, we talked about this earlier, Creed, that our text thread with you, the three of us, brings us such joy. We can always count on you for a cat video. Oh, yes.
但这种家庭连结是如此强大。这给我带来了最多的快乐，还有我的友谊和我的朋友们，你知道的。我现在向我的两个女孩伸出双手，她们基本上就像是我的女儿一样，你知道的。而且你一直以来在某种程度上也确实如此，你知道的。我一直都有这种感觉。嗯，我们之前讨论过这个，克里德，我们三个人的那个聊天群，给我们带来了这么多的快乐。我们总能指望你发来猫咪视频。噢，是的。
Or just how you refer to us, you always call Jenna, Jen. You call me Pumpkin and you call yourself Grandad Creed. Granddad Creed. That's true. Yeah. Lucky us. Lucky us. Yeah.
或者就凭你称呼我们的方式，你总是叫珍娜“珍”。你叫我“南瓜”，然后你叫自己“克里德爷爷”。克里德爷爷。确实如此。是的。我们真幸运。我们真幸运。是的。
Well, Creed, okay. More questions. more questions for you, but you're just such a delight. I'm just, from the minute, like, when I pulled up, he said, I just have a spring in my step today. Yep, good to see you guys. Getting to see us. So sweet. Okay.
好吧，克里德，好的。还有更多问题。还有更多给你准备的问题，但你真是太讨人喜欢了。我从一开始——比如，当我把车开过来时，他说：“我今天真是春风得意。”没错，很高兴见到你们。能见到我们。太贴心了。好的。
Creed, did you keep anything from the set after the series ended? You know, a sprinter van, a couple of cameras, some sound, some sound, noggara sound recorders, you know, like that. But, you know, I can, by the way, if you can get a hold of me, I can sell them to you. a little discreet scale. No, I saved the little samurai warrior with the fat samurai warrior with the fan on my desk. I have that on my mantle. That's great. But I asked permission, not like the character.
克里德，剧集结束后，你从片场留下了什么东西吗？你知道的，一辆短程旅行车（Sprinter van）、几台相机、一些录音设备，一些录音设备，纳加拉（Nagra）录音机之类的东西，你知道的，诸如此类。但是，你知道的，顺便说一句，如果你能联系到我，我可以把它们卖给你。一个微型隐蔽的天平。不，我把我桌上那个带扇子的胖武士小雕像留作纪念了。我把它放在我的壁炉台上了。那太棒了。不过我是征得同意的，不像那个角色。
I actually went to production and said, can I? Yes, of course. Of course that. And the suit that I wore in the finale when I'm in the white suit. That kind of a gray, that kind of linen suit. with a little purple thing and they're very it was tailored for me and stuff too they just gave that to me so i got to keep that so that let me think about that so the um yeah the the samurai guy and the uh and a couple of and maybe a picture there might be a picture from the wall there yeah you had a
我实际上是去制作组问的，我说：“我可以拿吗？”可以，当然可以。当然可以。还有我在大结局里穿的那套西装，就是那套白西装。那种灰色、那种亚麻西装。带着一点紫色的配饰，它们非常……而且也是专门为我量身定制的，他们就把那个送给我了，所以我得以留下了它。所以让我想想看，嗯，对，那个武士雕像，还有，嗯，还有几个，也许还有一张照片，墙上可能有一张照片，对，你墙上有
bunch of plaques on the wall by you they made they came up with pictures of me and my kids and stuff and put them but we all had that right all yeah yeah that was so great about the show they put personal stuff up on the desk, you know. You also had that dust buster on the wall next to you. Yes, I never used it. I never used it because somebody else would always come by. When I do my show and I sing the office theme, I talk about you and Phyllis and I always say, you know, Phyllis and Angela were the planning committee, you know.
一堆牌匾，旁边挂着制作组弄来的我和我孩子的照片之类的东西，然后把它们挂了上去，但我们都有那个，对吧？对，对，对，那个节目的棒就棒在这里，他们会把私人物品挂在桌子上，你知道的。你旁边墙上还挂着那个手持吸尘器。是的，我从来没用过它。我从来没用过，因为总会有别人过来。当我做我的节目并演唱《办公室》主题曲时，我会谈到你和菲利斯，我总是说，你知道的，菲利斯和安吉拉是策划委员会成员，你知道的。
A lot of people don't know this that Phyllis and Angela are method actors. So art design and props and people would come in and want to set the office up for the... No, they'd chase them all out. Then you guys would do all the work. We'd be home at night after showers and dinner. You'd still be there sitting up the office the next day. And, of course, they go, oh, it's probably true then. There's no telling what people believe about us.
很多人不知道这一点，菲利斯和安吉拉是体验派演员。所以美工设计、道具师和工作人员会进来，想要把办公室布置好……不，她们会把这些人全都赶跑。然后你们俩就会包揽所有的活。我们晚上洗完澡吃完晚饭回到家时。你们俩还坐在那里，准备着第二天要用的办公室。然后，当然，他们就会说：“哦，那可能就是真的了。”人们对我们的看法真是千奇百怪。
They're not. They're not. Just like, they're getting it, you know. Of course they would. They're actors, you know. Someone asked me one time, they were like, Creed said you're 411, but I think. you're a little taller. Are you telling people I'm 411? I took days 311, 411. I know it's changes
他们不是。他们才不是。就像是，他们懂的，你知道的。他们当然会懂。他们是演员，你知道的。有人曾问过我一次，他们说：“克里德说你身高四英尺十一英寸（4'11"），但我认为你稍微高一点。”你是不是在跟别人说我身高四英尺十一英寸？我拿过三天三英尺十一英寸、四英尺十一英寸。我知道它在舞台上变来变去的。
around on stage. All right, guys, whatever Creed says on stage, don't believe. It's true. Or believe, but with like a grain of salt. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. It's there for your amusement, folks. All right, Creed. Up next, we're going to do our call sheet questions. Okay, number one, what was your first job in entertainment? 1964, and I became an extra on camera on a movie called Cast a Giant Shadow with Mel Shabelson and the director. I fell in love with his daughter, Lynn, and we had an affair in the Greek islands after that.
好了，伙计们，克里德在舞台上说的话，什么都别信。千真万确。或者半信半疑吧。对。对，没错。乡亲们，那是为了博君一笑。好了，克里德。接下来，我们要进行我们的通告单问答环节。好的，第一个问题，你在娱乐圈的第一份工作是什么？1964年，我成为了一部名为《卡斯台巨影》（Cast a Giant Shadow）的电影中的背景演员，该片由梅尔·沙贝尔森（Mel Shavelson）担任导演。我爱上了他的女儿琳（Lynn），之后我们在希腊群岛有一段情缘。
But in the movie, the movie was Frank Sinatra, John Wayne, Yule Brenner, Senta Burger, and it was the Colonel Mickey Marcus, Kirk Douglas, who's played Colonel Mickey Marguards, the Israeli war for independence. What did you have to do in your scene? I was in English. I was there in a background. Yeah. But I got paid.
但在这部电影里，电影里有弗兰克·辛纳屈（Frank Sinatra）、约翰·韦恩（John Wayne）、尤·伯连纳（Yul Brynner）、森塔·伯杰（Senta Berger），还有扮演以色列独立战争中米奇·马库斯上校（Colonel Mickey Marcus）的柯克·道格拉斯（Kirk Douglas）。你在你的场景里要做什么？我是一个英国人。我在背景里。是的。但我拿到了片酬。
I was in a uniform. And you were a British soldier. A British soldier standing there. But attention, like the camera came by. Oh, wow. My first movie. That's a lot of big names. It's a huge movie.
我穿着制服。你是个英国士兵。一个站在那里的英国士兵。但是要立正，就像镜头扫过来的时候。哦，哇。我的第一部电影。有很多大人物。这是一部大制作电影。
If you watch the movie, can you find yourselves in the scene? Yes. Yes, yes. But the side of my face. Okay. There's an interesting story from that. I'm standing on the set and leaning against this. this wall, Frank Sinatra is there, and he sees me over there.
如果你看了这部电影，你能在这场戏里找到你自己吗？能。能，能。但是只有我的侧脸。好吧。这背后有一个有趣的故事。我站在片场，靠着这堵墙，弗兰克·辛纳屈就在那里，他看到了那边的我。
And I said, I'm like, wow, it's Frank Sinatra. He comes over to me like this, you know, and he goes, hey, kid, you know. He said, that wall is going to explode here in a little bit with squibs in there like that. You might want to just, you want, oh. And I said, well, thank you, Mr. Stein. He said, it's all right. So he just pushed me, pulled me away from the things I wouldn't get blown up, you know. Thank you, Frank.
然后我说，我就像是在想，哇，那是弗兰克·辛纳屈。他就像这样朝我走过来，你知道的，他说：“嘿，孩子，你知道吗。”他说，“那堵墙过一会儿就要爆炸了，里面装了微型炸药之类的东西。”你可能想要……哦。我说：“哦，谢谢你，斯坦先生。”他说：“没关系。”于是他推了我一把，把我从那个东西旁边拉开，免得我被炸飞，你知道的。谢谢你，弗兰克。
Wow. That's such a cool story that you had a conversation. Frank Sinatra. That's life. That's my life, perhaps. Wow. All right. Here is a question. Can you tell us all of the musical instruments that you play? It won't take long. Okay. Guitar, a little bit of piano, and a very little bit of mandolin. Okay. And a trumpet. I played trumpet for over 10, 12 years as a kid. That was my first instrument. Was trumpet? Trumpet. I did not know that. Yeah. That list is long. longer than our list, Creve.
哇。你和弗兰克·辛纳屈有过对话，这真是一个太酷的故事了。这就是人生。也许这就是我的人生吧。哇。好吧。这里有一个问题。你能告诉我们所有你会演奏的乐器吗？花不了多长时间。好的。吉他，一点点钢琴，还有非常少量的曼陀林。好的。还有小号。我小时候吹过十、十二年的小号。那是我的第一件乐器。是小号？小号。我不知道这个。是的。这个清单比我们的清单还要长，克里德。
That's right. But guitar is it, yeah. You have so many when you go to your place, you have like a wall of guitars. Yeah, yeah. Pretty cool. All right. What's a place that you've been to that you absolutely loved?
没错。但吉他才是王道，对吧。你去你那地方的时候有那么多吉他，你有一整面墙的吉他。对，对。太酷了。好了。你去过哪个地方是你绝对热爱的？
So many. Iceland. You're going there. But I drove around for two weeks. No navigation, no maps or anything. maps or anything, just drove, because it's an island, so you can't get really lost, you know. Fascinating, fascinating place. I love, and I've gone back numerous times with my son, the Sacramento River out of Reading, and taking it all.
太多了。冰岛。你们正要去那里。但我开车转了两周。没有导航，没有地图之类的东西，就是开车，因为那是一个岛，所以你实际上不会迷路，你知道的。迷人，迷人的地方。我喜欢，而且我和我儿子一起去过雷丁（Redding）附近的萨克拉门托河（Sacramento River）好多次，尽情享受这一切。
You can, and you're also the Klamath River at the Oregon, California border. Because you guys go fishing. We go fishing every year, practically, yeah. And we go to their back, I love it. I just love being on the river, the serenity, the beauty, and the fish, the beautiful fish. All catch and release, barbellous hooks. That sounds so peaceful. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
你可以去，还有俄勒冈州和加利福尼亚州边界的克拉马斯河（Klamath River）。因为你们去钓鱼。我们基本上每年都去钓鱼，真的。我们还会去他们那边，我太喜欢了。我就是喜欢身处河畔，那种宁静、美丽，还有鱼，美丽的鱼。全部都是catch and release（钓后放生），用的是无倒刺钓钩。听起来太宁静了。对，对，对。
I think the fish look forward to being caught with us. You want to just chat for a second? Yeah, let me talk and see what's going on. Yeah, love the commercial treat. Thank you. Boat back to your kids. All right, it's a good. All right.
我觉得鱼儿们都很期待被我们钓上来呢。你想聊一会儿吗？行，让我说两句，看看怎么回事。耶，真爱那个广告，克里德。谢谢。把船划回给你们的孩子们。好吧，很好。好吧。
Next question. What do you like to do on the weekends? Well, it's pretty boring. And pretty boring now. I read my books and I play my guitar and write my songs and do my yoga, swim. So I'll be one of this. I'll be swimming, doing yoga, you know. I like to go to Hugo's and have my almond energy pancakes, you know, meet my friends there. And you know that place. Love, love Hugo's. We love Hugo's. Yeah. They came in one day and said, hey, you were in. I went to, well, there you go. She knows a good pancake, obviously. So what kind of books do you like? Do you like fiction, nonfiction, both?
下一个问题。你周末喜欢做什么？嗯，挺无聊的。现在挺无聊的。我读书、弹吉他、写歌、练瑜伽、游泳。所以我会做这些。我会游泳、练瑜伽，你知道的。我喜欢去雨果餐厅（Hugo's）吃我的杏仁能量煎饼，你知道的，在那里见见我的朋友们。你们知道那个地方。爱死、爱死雨果餐厅了。我们爱雨果餐厅。对。他们有一天走过来对我说：“嘿，你来过。”我去过，嗯，这就对了。她显然很懂什么叫好煎饼。那你喜欢什么类型的书？你喜欢小说、非小说，还是两者都喜欢？
Both, both. Do you have something you've read recently that you like? We love to get out book shoutouts. I can't. I'm not really good at the names anymore. I basically have for a while, though, I have just written a book, a Western. It's on Amazon right now with my friend Nathan Edmondson called Buffalo. You did?
两者都喜欢，两者都喜欢。你最近读过什么你喜欢的书吗？我们喜欢在节目里推荐图书。我不行了。我记人名和书名越来越不行了。不过我有一段时间一直在写一本书，一本西部小说。现在它正在亚马逊上出售，是我和我的朋友南森·埃德蒙森（Nathan Edmondson）合著的，名叫《水牛城》（Buffalo）。你写了？
I wrote a book. We took two years to write the book. I had an eye. It's fact, I was talking about Hugo's. I was sitting in Hugo's one day, and this rider came by, who was Nathan. And he said, hey, I just want to tell you a big fan. And I said, I like, because he was an intelligent guy right off the bat. I went, sit down.
我写了一本书。我们花了两年时间来写这本书。我有一次……事实上，我刚才还在说雨果餐厅。有一天我坐在雨果餐厅里，这位作家走过来了，也就是南森。他说：“嘿，我只是想告诉你，我是你的超级粉丝。”我说：“我很喜欢……”因为他一开始就是个聪明人。我说：“坐下。”
We started talking. He had to deal with Paramount for a couple of scripts. And I told him this idea I had. And next thing we know, we were taking hands to write this thing together. And you did. And we did. And we're out now, folks, Buffalo. I love a Western.
我们开始聊了起来。他当时要跟派拉蒙（Paramount）谈几个剧本的事。我把我的这个想法告诉了他。接下来我们所知道的就是，我们携手开始一起写这个东西了。而你们真的写出来了。我们确实写出来了，伙计们，现在已经出版了，《水牛城》。我喜欢西部片。
I'll go check that out. So I, it's getting back to your point, Jen. I read all the, the Cormac McCarthy, the Laramick Merchries, the Louis Lamores. Yeah. I love all those Westerns. sci-fi, Neil Steffeson, William Gibson. I just finished Hyperion for the second time. That's an amazing sci-fi.
我要去看看。所以，我……回到你的观点上来，珍。我读所有的科马克·麦卡锡（Cormac McCarthy）、拉勒米·麦卡锡（Laramie Mercuries）、路易斯·拉穆尔（Louis L'Amour）的作品。是的。我喜欢所有这些西部片。还有科幻小说，尼尔·斯蒂芬森（Neal Stephenson）、威廉·吉布森（William Gibson）。我刚刚第二次读完《海伯利安》（Hyperion）。那是一部了不起的科幻小说。
All right. Last question. Favorite midnight snack? I don't eat at night. I know this. I don't. At 6 o'clock, when the sun goes down, then there's no food after that, you know. Yeah.
好的。最后一个问题。最喜欢的午夜零食？我晚上不吃东西。你知道的。我不吃。到了六点钟，太阳落山后，之后就绝对没有食物了，你知道的。是的。
You don't eat after 6. No. And then your first meal in the morning, what is that? Um, I will have been recently. I used to just have a cup of coffee and then write for a while, you know. But now I've been getting into these little gluten-free blueberry muffins. Hmm. A trout turned me onto them.
你六点以后不吃东西。不吃。那你在早上的第一顿饭是什么？嗯，我最近一直在吃……我以前只喝一杯咖啡，然后写一会儿东西，你知道的。但现在我迷上了这种无麸质蓝莓玛芬蛋糕。唔。有个鳟鱼（Trout）把我带坑里去了。
But there's a place I go to Giorla, it's just called that I go down and then get these gluten-free blueberry muffins with my coffee. Then I go home and then I write for about an hour, then I'll have breakfast, you know. Do you write in a journal? I write a longhand. Yeah. And then I put it, but I've started to kind of know that I'm wasting a lot of time writing a longhand. But I didn't think I could do it other ways. But now I'm starting to kind of slowly type.
但有个地方我常去，叫乔拉（Giorla），名字就叫这个，我过去那儿买这些无麸质蓝莓玛芬蛋糕配我的咖啡。然后我回家，接着写大约一个小时，然后我才吃早饭，你知道的。你写日记吗？我用手写。是的。然后我把它放进……但我开始意识到，我手写浪费了很多时间。但我以前觉得我没法用别的方式写。但现在我开始慢慢用打字了。
But it's like, it's like chicken back. Chicken back. It gets it. That's probably just as fast as writing longhand. How long have you kept a journal? Oh, a long time. Yeah. I think it's really important because the song lyrics are on their notes.
但这就像是……就像是鸡爪爬出来的字。鸡爪爬。那可能和手写一样快。你写日记有多久了？哦，很久了。是的。我觉得这真的很重要，因为歌词就在我的便签上。
And I have a, in my day planner, I have all things I'm supposed to do. And then at night, I'll look at my day planner and I'll write out a little notion of plan and put it up in the kitchen. Your cheat sheet. The cheat sheet. This is what you, yeah, that's a short, abbreviated version of what I'm going to do that day so that I can get to the satisfaction of checking off that and then going to the planner and checking it again.
而且我有一个……在我的日程规划本里，写着所有我应该做的事情。然后到了晚上，我会看看我的日程规划本，写下一个小小的计划构想，把它贴在厨房里。你的小抄。小抄。这就是你……对，那是你要做的那天事情的一个简短缩写版，这样我就可以获得勾选掉它的满足感，然后再去日程规划本上再次把它勾掉。
Yeah. Accomplishment. Did it. Double check accomplishment. Well, before we let you go, we got this letter from Juliana R in New York, who said, Creed came to my college as our fall comedian, and it was so exciting getting to listen to his music and hear him speak. I was on the Activities Council Board, so I even got to take a picture with him. What a gem.
是的。成就感。搞定。双重勾选成就感。好吧，在我们让你离开之前，我们收到了纽约朱莉安娜·R（Juliana R）的一封信，信里说：“克里德作为我们的秋季喜剧演员来到了我的大学，能听他的音乐并听他演讲真是太令人兴奋了。我是活动理事会成员，所以我甚至有机会和他合影。真是个宝藏人物。”
And it's true, Creed. Your live shows are so great. Have you had a recent live show, or do you have one coming up that you can share about? I did a show recently with Rain and his guest with Pete Holmes. I sang three songs, and I think he was one of them, one of my new songs. Yeah, I go out. I'll be going in October to Hawaii, New Zealand, Australia, Singapore, and Japan for the month of October. So I'll be doing my shows then, too. That's amazing. And on the drive-in, you pointed out a place and you're like, I play there once a month. The baked potato. I played there for a long time coming in and just doing like four songs with the very channel of Tim Hockenberry and his band. And now I have a band called The Work.
千真万确，克里德。你的现场演出太棒了。你最近有做过现场演出吗，或者你有什么即将举行的演出可以和大家分享吗？我最近和雷恩（Rain）以及他的嘉宾皮特·霍姆斯（Pete Holmes）一起做了一场演出。我唱了三首歌，我想其中有一首是我的新歌。对，我要出门了。我将在十月份去夏威夷、新西兰、澳大利亚、新加坡和日本呆上一个月。所以到时我也会去进行我的演出。太棒了。你在开车过来的路上，指出一个地方，然后你说：“我一个月在那儿演出一次。”烤土豆（The Baked Potato）。我在那儿演了很长时间，进去只是和蒂姆·霍肯伯里（Tim Hockenberry）以及他的乐队一起唱个四首歌。现在我有了个乐队叫“The Work”。
with Dylan O'Brien, Charlie Ferreger, Davy Ferreger, Sebastian Lorenz. They're called the work. We just did jam in the van, jam in the van, and we just played also, I must myself, a solo show, two solo shows with the band at the baked potato. And we'll let you know. I want to go to the baked potato. It's a fun little room, venerable jazz room. Of course, I'm creeds pop and fokey stuff, but they allow me to play. So great. Well, one last thing, because you said this in the car and we said we would talk about
成员有迪伦·奥布莱恩（Dylan O'Brien）、查理·费雷格（Charlie Ferleger）、戴维·费雷格（Davy Ferreger）、塞巴斯蒂安·洛伦兹（Sebastian Lorenz）。他们叫“The Work”。我们刚刚在“Jam in the Van”录制了节目，我们还刚演过……我自己，一场个人演出，在烤土豆乐队的两场个人演出。我们会让你知道的。我想去烤土豆餐厅。那是一个有趣的小房间，一家历史悠久的爵士乐俱乐部。当然，我是克里德那种流行和民谣的东西，但他们允许我演出。太棒了。好吧，最后一件事，因为你在车里说过这个，我们说我们会聊聊
it, which is Creed told me, you know, years ago, I would have these Yankee swap Christmas parties with the cast and they would come over. And I haven't had one in a long time. Jenna, you've started having some with your family, but that big get-together of the cast, you know, life happened, kids and just busyness. And he got in the car and he's like, I just want you to know, I've been holding on to a Yankee swap gift I bought for 15 years. For your next party. It's true. Because right off the veil, I loved it so much.
这个，就是克里德告诉我：“你知道的，多年前，我会和演员们举办白色大象交换圣诞礼物派对（Yankee swap Christmas parties），他们都会过来。”我已经好久没办过了。珍娜，你开始和你的家人举办一些了，但演员们那种大型聚会，你知道的，生活琐事、孩子们的出生以及各种忙碌。他上车后说：“我只是想让你知道，我一直保留着一份我买来已经15年的白色大象交换礼物。为了你的下一个派对。”千真万确。因为一出炉我就太喜欢它了。
And I was like, what? And he goes, I'm ready. You got to have your Yankee swap party and tell him what it is. I'm at a, what do they call it, a pawn shop or something like that? And I look down there and what it is, it's a toilet fishing, a toilet fishing game. We sit on the toilet and you lay this thing of a piece of paper. It's a lake. It's a lake.
然后我说：“什么？”他说：“我已经准备好了。你得办你的白色大象交换礼物派对，并告诉大家那是什么。”我在一个……他们管它叫什么，当铺还是什么地方？我往下看，那是什么东西，是一个厕所钓鱼游戏，一个厕所钓鱼游戏。我们坐在马桶上，然后你把这个东西铺在一张纸上。这是一个湖。这是一个湖。
And you spread it out on the floor and then it's got little fish, little magnet fish, and it's got a little fishing rod. And you go like this and you're on the toilet. go, and you drag the bag, you catch the fish, so you're fishing on the toilet. And I said, I really, because everyone will want this for sure. He's been holding on to it for like a decade. I would sit in my garage. It won't get rid of it. All right. Can I make a suggestion? It doesn't have to be December to have a fun Yankee swap party. This is true. Like, let's pick a time. I got to get this out of my life. December. Yeah. Let's, this party needs to happen early. It's going to be
你把它铺在地板上，然后里面有小鱼，磁铁小鱼，还有一根小鱼竿。你就像这样坐在马桶上，然后……然后你把线扔出去，你钓到鱼，所以你是在马桶上钓鱼。我说，我真的很……因为每个人肯定都会想要这个。他把它留了足足有十年之久。我就把它放在我的车库里。就是不肯扔掉。好吧。我能提个建议吗？要办一个有趣的白色大象交换礼物派对，不一定非得等到十二月。确实如此。比如，我们挑个时间。我得把这东西弄出我的生活。十二月。是的。让我们……这个派对得提前办。那就定在
office reunion slash cast friends slash Yankee Swap in July. Yes. I don't know. Maybe so. Yeah. All right. All right. All right.
七月份的《办公室》重聚斜杠演员朋友斜杠白色大象交换礼物派对。是的。不知道。也许吧。好吧。好吧。好吧。
Oh, my gosh. Girls, it's always, it's just a joy seeing you both. I love you both. You know them. Thank you for having me. And thanks for all the fans for those kind words. And, uh, oh, Crete's a lucky guy. Thank you.
噢，天哪。女孩们，一直以来，见到你们俩就是一种快乐。我爱你们俩。你们懂的。谢谢你们邀请我。也谢谢所有粉丝那些暖心的话语。而且，哦，克里德是个幸运的家伙。谢谢。
We love you, Cree. I love you guys. Well, lady, I just loved having Creed in studio with us. I did too. It was such a treat. And as we finish up today, we got a fan letter from Jamie T. in Arizona. I really liked this. Jamie said, I have a theory as to what happened to Creed after the final episode.
我们爱你，克里德。我也爱你们，伙计们。好了，各位女士，我太喜欢克里德和我们一起在录音室了。我也是。这真是一种享受。随着我们今天接近尾声，我们收到了亚利桑那州杰米·T（Jamie T.）的一封粉丝来信。我真的很喜欢这个。杰米说：“我有一个关于大结局后克里德发生了什么的理论。”
Oh. I think after being taken away by the police, he jumped bail, used his passport with his name, William Charles Schneider and fled the country. He could now be living in a country with no extradition treaty with the United States and is the leader of a cult to make money. Probably not far off. It's true. It's probably pretty great, Jamie. But lady, did the NBC website say what Creed is up to? I couldn't find it. Oh, no. I search, if someone else out there found it on the NBC website, let me know. I got tons of clips of Creed, but I couldn't find like a where is he now thing. Okay.
哦。我认为在被警察带走后，他保释潜逃了，用他叫威廉·查尔斯·施耐德（William Charles Schneider）名字的护照逃离了这个国家。他现在可能生活在一个与美国没有引渡条约的国家，并且是一个邪教领袖来赚钱。”可能八九不离十。确实如此。杰米，这可能挺精彩的。但是，女士们，NBC网站上有说克里德在干什么吗？我没找到。哦，不。我搜了，如果外面的其他人谁在NBC网站上找到了，请告诉我。我找到了大量克里德的剪辑，但我找不到那种“他现在在哪里”之类的东西。好的。
But I did find this great article on Collider with a quote from Creed Bratton in real life about what he thinks happened to the character Creed. Okay. So I thought I would share that. So this article kind of breaks down everyone's final moments on the show. And Collider's like, you know, everyone gets kind of a happy ending except for Creed who gets handcuffed and is presumably going to prison for the crimes he's committed. Yes.
但我确实在Collider网站上找到了一篇很棒的文章，里面引用了现实生活中的克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）关于他认为角色克里德发生了什么的话。好的。所以我想我可以分享一下。所以这篇文章算是剖析了每个人在剧中的最后时刻。Collider网站就说，你知道的，每个人都有一个相对美满的结局，除了克里德，他被戴上手铐，据推测要为他犯下的罪行入狱。是的。
So Collider says you would think the logical place for Creed, now is prison, but here is what Creed Bratton, the actor, thinks. In an interview with the Tampa Bay Times in 2019, Bratton speculated about the character's future saying, quote, he never stayed in jail long. He got out pretty fast. He went on to suggest that Creed would have gotten pity from a talented defense attorney, scammed his way to freedom, and continued doing probably the illegal things that Creed does best. And honestly, Bratton makes a good point. After all, Creed got away with it this long, so why wouldn't he be able to escape justice again? Well, this is not too far off from Jamie's theories.
所以Collider说，你可能会认为克里德现在合乎逻辑的去处是监狱，但演员克里德·布拉顿是这么认为的。在2019年接受《坦帕湾时报》（Tampa Bay Times）采访时，布拉顿对这个角色的未来进行了推测，引用原话：“他在监狱里从没呆多久。他很快就出来了。”他接着暗示，克里德会从一位才华横溢的辩护律师那里获得同情，通过诈骗重获自由，并继续做克里德最擅长的那些大概是非法的事情。说实话，布拉顿说的很有道理。毕竟，克里德逍遥法外这么久了，他为什么不能再次逃脱法律的制裁呢？嗯，这跟杰米的理论相差不远。
Exactly. But Cassie, you said that when you were walking Creed out, he had an idea of where we might be able to see Creed again, which I thought was pretty fun. Yeah, will you share your conversation? Yeah, I was like, oh, I would love to know what Creed is up to and maybe we'll get to know through the paper. And he was saying that he pitched to Greg that maybe one episode, We just see him working in the background at a random office.
没错。但卡西（Cassie）你曾说过，当你送克里德离开时，他对我们在哪里能再次见到克里德有一个想法，我觉得这挺有意思的。是的，你愿意分享一下你们的对话吗？是的，我说，哦，我很想知道克里德在忙什么，也许我们可以通过报纸了解。然后他说，他向格雷格（Greg）提议，也许在某一集里，我们能看到他在一个随机的办公室背景里打杂。
So, like, I guess we just have to really be looking in the background for a creed catch. That would make me so happy. If Creed was just somewhere in the deep background, maybe he's at Softies, the toilet paper company. Or, you know what I would love? I would love to see him, like, delivering someone's meal at that little place where they eat lunch in the building. Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
所以，就像，我想我们真的必须睁大眼睛在背景里寻找克里德的身影了。那会让我太高兴了。如果克里德只是在某个深深的背景里，也许他在“Softies”纸巾公司。或者，你知道我希望看到什么吗？我希望看到他，比如在那座大楼里他们吃午饭的小地方给某人送外卖。是的。是的。是的。
Yeah. Maybe he catches the documentary crew and immediately runs away. he's like not again. All right. Well, everyone, thank you so much for sending in your questions for all about Creed. And thank you to Creed for coming in and spending this afternoon with us. Oh, and we want to give a shout out to a project for Creed. He shared with us he performed in the YouTube series called Jam in the Van. It's a series where musicians perform in a van. And he's really great in it. We'll add it to our stories. I love it. Such a fun day. I love. our job. I love the cast of the office, and I love our Office Ladies community. Thank you guys so much. See you next week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is
是的。也许他撞见了纪录片摄制组然后立刻逃跑了。他就像是“怎么又是你们”。好吧。好了，各位，非常感谢大家发来关于“全关于克里德”的问题。也谢谢克里德来到这里和我们度过这个下午。哦，我们想为克里德的一个项目打call。他跟我们分享了他在YouTube系列节目《Jam in the Van》中的表演。这是一个音乐家在房车里表演的系列节目。他在里面的表现真的太棒了。我们会把它加到我们的动态里。我太喜欢了。多么有趣的一天。我爱我们的工作。我爱《办公室》的演员阵容，我爱我们的“Office Ladies”社群。非常感谢大家。下周见。下周见。感谢收听 Office Ladies。Office Ladies 是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金斯利（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubbico）。Odyssey 的执行制片人是
Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。Office Ladies 的混音和母带制作由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Shultz）完成。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertry》。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。